during the coronavirus pandemic
telehealth apps have seen a surge in
popularity
with just a click patients can speak to
their doctors on their phones
bypassing sitting in offices potentially
being exposed to covet 19.
rick ross rapper and celebrity
entrepreneur is cashing in on the
explosion
it began 10 years ago i believe it began
with my first seizure that i suffered
i've been healthy i've been an athlete
my my entire life
so me becoming an artist me traveling
flying five times a week me you know up
in the studio
up to you know up towards you know 20
hours a day possibly
uh it actually took a toll on me you
know i began i had a seizure
i got up for my very first one walked
away from it
you know me being a young black male
never was accustomed to going to the
doctor always felt it was a huge
inconvenience
i had a seizure on the flight called a
private jet 45 minutes later i was on
the jet
flying off again i had another one i
woke up in a different situation that i
just couldn't walk from
so i believe that was personally my
introduction to jet dock
obviously covert 19 has absolutely
changed the way we
access and how often we can access our
healthcare professionals so
telehealth which was once kind of a
wonky you know video conference
feature that clinics offered is now
becoming a necessity
healthcare analyst craig suttle says
he's a fan of jetdock's business model
but says that racial disparities in
healthcare as an issue
is way too complex for one startup to
handle
so in general i would say
that um there are disparities
in the uh delivery of
health care in many uh
low-income communities and then there is
a
direct and indirect biases
that are part of the health care
system or the delivery and so there is a
general
distrust among african-american
people what i originally thought was
going to be a
fabulous lifestyle story featuring rick
ross
about his health resolutions for the new
year his newfound lifestyle
morphed into something greater and we
began to really explore
healthcare and disparities within
healthcare
by interviewing him as well as the
founder of jet doc
like ross i actually had a health scare
but i was 30
i had a stroke um
you know he's been building his music
career
i've been building my entrepreneurial
in healthcare and at that moment in time
i was super stressed out
you know just trying to do a lot i just
got married
just had my first song and you know when
you're an entrepreneur you have a lot of
weight
and it i ended up in the hospital jet
dock is setting itself from
other players in the market by targeting
people of color
especially african-american men which is
why they hired rick ross
as its strategic partner we are not a
health insurance company
we do not require health insurance you
can think of us
as a club a debt doc health club
you know i talked about the
legacy of bad experiences
with the health care system right so if
you can bring
these celebrities uh and then rob
furthers and these guys are obviously
you know part of that if you can bring
those folks
into the community and ensure
and ensure that people are comfortable
with the concept then it makes it
possible then
for a product such as this to
um be beneficial because it'll be
well received i've struggled with weight
loss my entire life
and i've finally made my mind up over
the last five years i've lost
80 plus pounds i've addressed
and adjusted certain eating habits of
course my sleeping habits
which i think was my my largest fault um
and like you say being a
black male a father a brother a son
a entrepreneur a artist a performer a
an actor or author
i could never do enough and i think um
it's something that you got to keep in
mind
i gotta have a doctor right here my
fingertips privacy
is a huge thing instead of walking into
a doctor being on tmz just because
i wanted to get a some advice from a
doctor i could just get it over the
phone
obviously telehealth has countless
benefits convenience wise and safety
wise
but i've spoken to other healthcare
entrepreneurs in the space including dr
burzin the founder of parsley health and
she actually recommends that you never
replace
your primary care physician with
telehealth
but telehealth is one way for the
healthcare industry
to better treat those with chronic
health issues
at scale
you